عندما لاحظ جلين موغ لأول مرة وجود كتلة في
حلقه، لم يفكر كثيرًا في الأمر لأنه
استمر في النمو، ظللت أحاول
إقناع نفسي بأنها مجرد
عقدة ليمفاوية مصابة، ولكن عندما
استمر الورم في النمو، رأى طبيبًا وعلم
أنه  كان يعاني من سرطان الحنجرة في المرحلة الرابعة على الرغم
مما يقول إنه لا يوجد تاريخ لأي سرطان
في عائلته، فأنت تعتقد تلقائيًا
أن الأسوأ يقول موك إن سرطانه كان
سببه فيروس الورم الحليمي البشري، وهو فيروس ينتشر
عبر الجلد الحميم إلى ملامسة الجلد
حتى لو لم تكن هناك أعراض، كما يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض.
تختفي معظم حالات الإصابة بفيروس الورم الحليمي البشري في غضون
عامين، لكن بعضها الآخر يستمر لفترة أطول
في الولايات المتحدة. يسبب فيروس الورم الحليمي البشري حوالي 36000 حالة
سرطان كل عام لدى كل من الرجال
والنساء. لم أكن أعرف شيئًا عن
فيروس الورم الحليمي البشري ولم أكن أعلم أنه يسبب ذلك.
أنت تعلم أن سرطان الحنجرة والرقبة يصيب الرجال في
الخمسينيات من العمر في العقد القادم، ويتوقع الخبراء في
مركز السرطان الشامل بجامعة ولاية أوهايو أن يكون سرطان الحلق المرتبط بفيروس الورم الحليمي البشري هو
النوع الأكثر شيوعًا من السرطان بين أولئك الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 45 إلى
65 عامًا.  فرصة
للحصول على لقاح جارداسيل أو اللقاح
ضد فيروس الورم الحليمي البشري، لذا
فقد تعرضوا بالفعل لهذا السبب
يقول الدكتور ماثيو أولد إنه من المهم بالنسبة
لهذه الفئة العمرية بشكل خاص معرفة
أعراض سرطانات الجزء الخلفي من الحلق
والتي غالبًا ما تبدأ بكتلة غير مؤلمة
في الرقبة، قد يعانون أيضًا من التهاب في
الحلق، وصعوبة في البلع، وفقدان الوزن، أو
تغيرات في صوتهم.
لن أعود أبدًا إلى
الوراء ولكن على الأقل لست مصابًا بالسرطان
من أجل الصحة، أنا آندي غايثر